Et que le neuf/06 prochain, c'est 1 référendum,
euh pour ou contre le délitement de la France.
alors je dis à tous les français, vous aimez la France,
la France est aujourd'hui, euh menacée de disparition,
sa voix est en train de s'éteindre,
alors allez voter pour la sauver.
Le neuf/06 est 1 choix entre 2 visions de l'Europe,
l'Europe de Macron avec euh 1 immigration imposée,
l'écologie punitive,
euh l'enfer euh fiscal pour nos chefs d'entreprise,
la concurrence des loyales, la garde tous contre tous
et face à ça, l'Europe des nations que je porte,
respectueuse des peuples, des nations, de leur identité,
de leur frontière, et surtout 1 Europe
du bon sens basée sur des réalités.
Voilà,
s'abstenir ou disperser ses voix le neuf/06 prochain,
c'est faire 1 petit cadeau à Emmanuel Macron.
Nous pouvons ouvrir la voix de l'alternance.
Alors je dis aux françaises que vous vivez,
c'est la conséquence de choix politique,
mais ça n'est pas 1 fatalité.